vous avez raison de dire que cette
élection intermédiaire est en général
difficile pour le pouvoir en place alors
elle n'a pas toujours été et c'est vrai
que les quelques dans l'histoire des
élections municipales il ya deux
élections qui ont montré des vagues
d'opposition très forte celle de 77 avec
notamment une victoire importante des
socialistes qui préparait d'ailleurs
d'une certaine manière la victoire
future de 80 il y avait une élection de
son 18 qui avait été un échec pour
l'union de la gauche mais ce sont 17 et
une élection extrêmement important pour
l'implantation de ce qu'on a appelé le
socialisme municipal
et puis vous avez eu 83 avec un refus là
en effet de la gauche municipale et une
victoire de la droite de l'udf et le rpr
de l'époque
mais ceci dit quand même ce qui est
frappant aujourd'hui dans la stratégie
qui est la stratégie politique dans
marche c'est que si vous voulez y a pas
le souci
le problème c'est pas seulement que ça
soit une élection intermédiaire
difficile pour le pouvoir c'est que
c'est aussi une élection intermédiaire
pour un président de la république qui
en difficulté avec le local etc à une
difficulté avec les collectivités
locales
parce que tout simplement il est
lui-même il n'est pas issu de ce cursus
honorum qui est le cursus traditionnel
delon politique qui passe par les
élections locales et puis qui
progressivement progresse donc il a
quand même d'une certaine manière dans
sa culture politique une culture
politique qui n'est pas fondamentalement
axée sur le local et on voit aujourd'hui
et on l'a vu encore même lors du congrès
de la haye mais fou son discours on peut
pas le dire que son discours était quand
même largement entendu on l'a vu avec le
congrès des départements et les
relations compliquées il a des relations
compliquées avec les collectivités
locales donc si vous voulez le contexte
en tant que tel de la relation
aujourd'hui de la majorité au local rend
encore plus difficile cette élection
cette élection municipale et on voit
bien que la stratégie finalement il est
très simple c'est vrai c'est d'essayer
de rendre illisibles les résultats et
essayer de rendre illisibles les
résultats et les enseignements nationaux
que l'on pourrait tirer de ce scrutin
mais je rajouterais que il n'est pas le
seul
parce que finalement quand on regarde
les sortants de ce que l'on appelle les
vieilles marques politique c'est à dire
autant des républicains que des partis
socialistes ils ne vont pas vraiment
faire campagne avec le drapeau est ce
bien
relevez ça fait très longtemps et vous
avez deux formations et vous avez
vraisemblablement deux formations qui
elles vont faire campagne
sous leurs propres sous leurs propres
couleurs et qui ont été à le faire c'est
d'un côté le rassemblement national et
de l'autre les verts qui eux veulent se
compter et veulent montrer qu'ils
deviennent des forces politiques qui
vont peser sur les scrutins à venir